Now it's time to set up the routing for
application.
In the mock-ups, we specify routes for
the following pages.
Note that landing on the root page
of our site will now route us to
the page that shows all
of the restaurants.
And, visiting /restaurant/menu ID will
automatically take us to the menu page.
Create a new Python file called,
finalproject.py in the same
directory as all of our other files.
Import the Flask module and the app.run
code, like in the previous lesson.
Add the routing for
all pages into finalproject.py and
create the following methods that return
the appropriate messages in the browser.
When you save and
fire up your browser, you should be
able to visit all of the URLs like so.
At the end of this iteration,
you have shown that you can
get a Flask application up and
running, accounting for all
the necessary pages your app will have.